we've now had three major bleaching
events on the Great Barrier Reef in 98
2002 and again just recently in 2016
we Zig zagged along the whole length in
helicopter and fixed-wing flying we put
about a hundred people underwater
the extent and severity of this
bleaching is off the chart
typically a bleached Karl is
nutritionally compromised but this time
around we discovered an additional
phenomenon many of the corals we
surveyed were already dead
they actually cooked and that's because
the temperatures this time around were
so extreme
already in 2016 severe coral bleaching
has also been recorded across the
Pacific Ocean in Fiji across the Indian
Ocean in the Maldives and the Seychelles
and even in the southern red sea similar
events are predicted across the
Caribbean and Micronesia in a year in
which the impacts of heat stress on the
global ocean have reached unprecedented
extremes as the distribution of marine
species continues to change as storm
surges continue to intensify as sea ice
and glacier melt accelerate and as sea
level rise and human displacement
intensifies
countries around the world in Paris last
year have committed to a rapid
transition away from fossil fuels
towards more sustainable renewable
energy Paris marked the moment when the
world finally decided to heed the ever
rising mountain of evidence that had
been piling up for years and began
instead to galvanize our focus
so in social acceptability recorded by
solution is a mission together if it's a
poor motel resilience mercy or
forgiveness your political terms of
modulated document emphasis or a
scenario venereal decompression of
library Mahina